Chicago Cubs yeah maybe everyone's
talking about it I want to jinx it but
they may finally break the curse and
this is a curse
i as you know grew up in Belton longtime
Boston Red Sox fan and I grew up with
misery after misery after misery after
misery we thought we would never see it
and the curse finally ended but for the
Cubs it's been a much longer curse than
even the Red Sox Red Sox won from 1918
to 2004 Cubs are still waiting since
1908 since 1908 Wrigley Field hadn't
even been built yet right Harry Caray
hadn't been born Harry Caray has come
and gone no Harry Caray was the
legendary right Cubs announcer but
there's a whole generation that only
knows him because Will Ferrell did an
impression of him right Unser now live
people don't know that no he was a he
was he was the iconic sports cast he was
bombastic and entertaining but for most
of his career he was genuinely great
yeah as a broadcaster and for whatever
reason he took a liking to me when I was
first breaking in and since most of the
games that Wrigley wordai games if I was
there he'd say come on kid let's go and
he was known as the mayor of Rush Street
and he stayed out till 3:00 4:00 o'clock
in the morning didn't matter and he
could drink a case of Budweiser which is
why it was so effective at selling it
during during games and so at one point
we're sitting in his restaurant Harry
Caray's and people are just coming up to
him everything from pretty young girls
to 90 year old men and they all adore
him and they want a photograph and an
autograph and I surveyed the scene and I
said Harry what's it all about
and with those big glasses and that
rumbling boys he goes what's it all
about kid what's it all about I'll tell
you what it's all about booze broads
baseball and [ __ ]
later in his career you were moments
where he was not always politically
correct fair uh yeah I don't even know
if I should tell this story because it
it would have gotten any of us fired
right on the spot right uh it when it
happened in the 1990s the Cubs had a
well traveled shortstop named Jose
Vizcaino and there was a pop into
shallow center and Vizcaino went out on
the centerfielder came in and they
looked each other off for a drop between
them and Harry's doing the game's on
he's on the eve on the air he's on the
air and you're mentioning people's
birthdays and mispronouncing people's
names and talking about where he's gonna
be going for dinner and saying whatever
occurs to him
so the ball drops and he was like a fan
he'd be so exasperated at things they
can go right for the Cubs and he turns
to stone he goes stave here's what I
want to know how could a guy from Mexico
lose a ball in the Sun now if anybody
else says that they don't die I'm after
the game they fire him like that yeah
yeah he sees yeah he says carry the best
part about it was this guy I know was
from the Dominican Republic
[Laughter]
you